翻訳: Kari C
校正: Hiroko Kawano
みなさんこんにちは
ビジョンクリイエーターの河森正治です
私は主にアニメーションの原作を考えたり
演出や監督をしたり
それからメカニックデザインの
仕事をしたりしています
その中でも 自分が一番大事にしているのは
オリジナリティ
本当にこの学校で
鍛えられたこともあるのですが
オリジナリティをすごく大事にしています
今回はオリジナリティを生み出す
多次元的発想法
何が多次元かは
見て頂いて と思うのですが
そんな話をしていきたいと思っています
では まずオリジナリティとは何か?
オリジナリティの話をしたら
それだけで１時間や２時間も経ってしまう
ような内容なのですけれども
大きく分けると
発明的なオリジナリティ
何もなかった
新しいものを生み出すタイプ
そしてもう一つは
一人一人の個性 自分らしさを活かした
パーソナリティを活かしたオリジナリティ
その二つが大きくあると思います
自分のパーソナリティーとしては
これは 56年前に
自分が生まれた富山の山奥の
当時は日本の秘境と
いわれていた村です
20年ほど前に
世界遺産に登録されたのですが
ここに写っている村 この辺に
ちょっと写っていない
ちょっと離れたところで生まれました
そこで３歳まで育ち
そして横浜に引っ越します
すごい山奥から出てきて
初めて見る蒸気機関車に興奮して
鼻血を出してたりとか
家出じゃないんですけど
行方不明になって
どっか行ったと思われていて
機関車を追いかけて
どんどん行ってしまったとか
そんなことをしていました
３歳児ながらに
カルチャーショックを受けて
そのカルチャーショックが
自分の中のモノ作りの原点になっています
初めて見るもの
びっくりしてワクワクして 感動する
そんな感動を伝えたい
そんな気持ちが芽生えた感じでした
まずそのオリジナリティを
生み出す上での一つのポイント
それは視点を変える
よく話に出るように
ものの見方を変えていくこと
自分の場合
この視点を変えるというのは
木登りで鍛えられました
子供の頃 横浜はすごく木が多い
この学校の中も木が多いですよね
30数年振りで来ると
すごい木が育って大きくなっていて
この木に登る時に ―
木の上に基地を作ってたんですけど
下から見上げると
友達の姿 普段見慣れない角度ですよね
そして木に登って見下ろす
頭の上から見るその姿
普段 二次元平面に暮らしていることが
多いんですけれども
木に登って高さという三次元が加わると
世界が違って見える
しかも木に登る時というのは
リスクがありますよね
滑るかもしれない
そしてこの枝の先に行ったら
折れて落ちるかもしれない
そのちょっとリスクがあることによって
何だろ？
原始的な本能というのかな？
人類がまだサルだった頃の
本能が活性化されて
すごくものの見方とかが
シャープになってくる
そんなことが自分の中でも
培われた体験になっていると思います
ではこの視点を変えるというのを
実際の仕事に応用するとどうなるのか？
一つ 実例です
これ本当に見慣れたセロテープの台ですね
引っ張っても動かないようにするために
すごく安定した形をしている
このセロテープの台を
逆さまにしてみたらどうなるのか？
急になんかこう不安定な感じになる？
今こうやってこう
不安定になるけど —
宙に浮いているような感じになる
そこでこういう宙に浮いているような
イメージをモチーフにすると
例えば こんな形が出来たりします
（歓声）
見慣れたセロテープが宇宙船に変わる
こんなのが視点を変える時の
一つのポイントですね
実際の仕事の例でいきます
［人型ロボットに代わる
新しい主役メカニックの開発］
30数年前 自分が大学２年生に在学中に
人間型ロボットに変わる主役メカをつくる
そんなプロジェクトに参加しました
大学に通いながら
仕事を始めていたので
ほとんど寝ない日々が
続いていたんですけれど
その中で 人間型ロボットって
いくらでもあったんですけれども
そうじゃない 人間じゃない形の主役メカ
脇役メカだったら
なんとかなるんですけど
主役メカを作ろうという
プロジェクトでした
なかなかできなくて
一年経っても出来ません
どんなに悩んでも考えても
どこかで見た形になってしまう
あとは主役にならない
もうどうにもならないので
気分転換にスキーに行きました
友達とスキーに行ったんですね
でそうしてスキーを滑っている時
こうやって滑りますよね
ちょっと見えにくいかも知れませんけど
ひざを曲げてスキーを滑ると
その時視点が変わるわけです
ひざを曲げた形 この形のメカは
今までないかもしれない
（笑）
でもこのひざを曲げただけだったら
ただ人間がひざを曲げただけだ
じゃあもう一回視点を変えてみよう
前と後ろを逆にする
そうすると関節が逆向きになった
メカができるんじゃないか？
そうやって思いついたのがこんな形です
ついにやったなと思いました
ついにこれで人型に代わる
主役メカが出来たと
ところがです
スポンサーに売り込みに行くと
「人型じゃないから売れませんね」
と言われるわけです
「人型じゃなきゃいらない」と
すごい悔しかったです
でも悔しがってばかりもいられないので
新しいプロジェクトに取り組みました
[VF-1 バルキリー開発]
マクロスシリーズの後に
主役メカになるんですけれども
じゃあ人型にしようと
でもただの人の形だとつまらないんで
飛行機から人型のロボットに変わる
そんなメカを作ろうと思ったわけです
そして学生時代 高校３年生のとき
すごい絵の上手い友達がいっぱいいたので
彼らと一緒に合作した漫画です
その時自分はメカニックデザインと
ストーリーを担当したんですけれども
ここに描いている人達 本当に
後にプロになって漫画家になったり
いろいろしているんですけれども
この時のデザインを元に
こんな形を作っています
これまだ小さいんですけれども
そこからさらに大きくして
本物の飛行機ぐらいの
サイズにしたのがこれですね
この時 人間の手がついている
この腕をこう前に畳んで
頭のあたりがコックピットになって
そんな形をいろいろ実験していました
何とかして飛行機に近いメカを
作ろうとしていたんですけど
なかなかリアリティーが上がりません
そんなことやっている時に
またこう言われました
「飛行機は売れない」と
（笑）
「今だかつて 飛行機が主役のメカは
売れたためしがないから止めて欲しい」と
「なんでこうなるんだろう」と
思うわけですね
でも否定された時こそ
絶好のチャンスだと思います
なぜならば みんなが否定するってことは
みんなやらないんですね
誰もやらないってことは
すごくチャンスがある
みんながやろうと飛びついていることで
そんな中で競争するのは
すごい大変ですよね
だけども 誰もやんないって
言っているんだったら
やりゃ良いじゃないかと
だからこそ 絶好のチャンスだと
思ってトライしました
その時 飛行機は売れないと言われたんで
もっと飛行機に もっと本物の飛行機に
近づけてやろうと思ったわけです
そして F-14トムキャット
有名な機体ですね
もう一度見直して 研究しました
機首が短い
さっきこう腕を前に畳んでも
機首が長いので
どうしても本物の飛行機っぽく見えなかった
そしてこの機体
エンジンが離れているんですね
普通もっと近い所にあるんですけれども
エンジンが離れていて
この隙間に
腕が畳めると閃いたわけです
視点が変わって下からみた時に
「ここ畳めるじゃん」と
そのおかげで一年以上かかって
なかなかできなかったアイデアが突破され
最初に描いたのがこのスケッチです
すごく寸詰りだから格好悪いけれども
そこからもう一週間もあれば
ここまでいきます
一旦ブレークスルーさえしてしまえば
後は速いんですね
ただブレークスルーするまでが
時間がかかる
その時に諦めないでいけるかどうか
というのがすごいポイントです
実際に試作品を持ち込んだとき
「飛行機は売れない」と
言ってたおもちゃ屋さんが
突然立ち上がって 「やりましょう」 と
言ってくれました
（笑）
とても嬉しい瞬間ですね
そして作ったのが
『超時空要塞マクロス』
自分が在学中のときの作品ですね
一緒のスタッフたちと共同で考えた原作で
物語を作っていきました
メカの方は自分でオリジナルなものが
できたと思うんですけれども
ストーリーにも何か画期的な
オリジナリティが欲しいと思いました
その時に「次元を変える」
今までにないタイプの
解決策が出来ないか？
それが 「武器ではない戦争解決」です
いろいろなSF、 宇宙戦争ものもあるし
本物の戦争ものもあるし
だけど 基本的に戦争というものに対して
武力で解決する
スーパーヒーローのパワーで解決する
それは基本的には 同じ次元の発想ですね
なので 戦争に対しての武力ではない
違った次元からのアプローチが出来ないか
なので 武器ではない解決というのを考え
ここに行き着きました
「歌によるカルチャーショック」
文化の力によって 戦争を終結させる
たまたま設定上
敵の異星人が文化を持たない
という設定にしていたので
歌の力で相手が感動して 戦争をやめる
そんなストーリーを思いつけたわけです
しかも勇壮な音楽ではなくて
ただのアイドルソングだ ―
宇宙戦争を止める
これならさすがに他の人も
やらないだろうなと思って作りました
そしてオリジナルを生み出す時の
一つの方法論として
なるべく異なる次元のものを
合体して 変形して 変容させる
例えば SF作品の多くでは
最近 アイデアに詰まると
ハイテクノロジーと神話
ものすごい古いものと
ものすごい新しいものを合体させた物語
これたくさん作られていますよね
そして例えば携帯電話
電話機とコンピューターと
テレビモニターとカメラが合体してる
そしてそれぞれの機能を 遥かに凌ぐぐらい
ライフスタイルを変更するぐらいまでの
インパクトを社会に与えています
そんな風に今までに もしあったものでも
全く違う組合せが出来たらば
新しいものが生まれる可能性は
秘められているわけです
そんな時 物事作る上での「感じる力」とか
「問いを生み出す力」というのが
すごい大切になります
何しろ何か見て
感動しないことには始まらない
それから問いを生み出すということ
これは誰かが問いかけた問いに対して
問題に対して答えを出す
ということではありません
テストの問題 先生が考えていたとしたら
先生は答えを知っています
ゲームをやる場合
もし攻略本があるとすれば
ゲームを作った人がどうやって
解けばいいかを知っているわけです
誰かが解答を知っているものに
どれだけ答えても
そこには決して
オリジナリティは生まれません
まだ問題がないところ
問題が存在していないと思うところから
謎を見つけ 不思議なことを見つけ
そこに何か問題があるんじゃないんだろうかと
そういう「問いを生み出す力」が
とても大事だと思うわけです
その問いを生み出す力を養うために
一つの方法論があります
「立脚点を変える」
さっき視点を変えると言ったのは
自分がここにいて
こうやって 物の見方
方向を変えることですね
でも立脚点を変えるというのは
もう少し変わっていて
自分は今ここでスピーカーとして
話していますけれども
この段を降りて この席に座って
観客として聞く
さっきまで聞いていてすごく面白かったです
皆さんのお話とても刺激的でした
立場を全部変えて
普段の自分じゃない立場に変えること
これが立脚点を変えるということです
役者のトレーニングとかで
いつもの自分を守ったまま
いろいろ考えてこんな風に
動くんじゃないかと思って芝居するタイプ
それとは逆に もう役になりきっちゃって
何にも考えないでできる
その 役になりきるという方が
この立脚点を変えるということの
感覚に近いと思います
例えば 日本を離れて
日本の価値観とは全然違う国に行く
そこの価値観を否定するのではなく
戸惑うだけではなく
その国の人になったつもりで感じてみる
例えば自分 これ簡単な話ですけれど
インドに行ったときに
カレーを食べるときに
手で食べるんですね
手でグチャグチャ混ぜて
最初ちょっと気持ち悪いんですけれども
しばらく慣れてくると
味が分かるようになってくるんです
触った瞬間に
「あ これはちょっとビリッとくるな
これ今日いいな
これはうまいんじゃないか」とか
その時 気づくんですね
手がすごいセンサーだったと
忘れていた感覚を思い出すわけです
そんな風に普段の自分をちょっと抜け出して
変わったことを体験してみる
そういうことによって
例えば 異文化を理解したり
他者を理解したり
そういうことにもなるし
普段の自分の考え方を変えることによって
新しいものの見方
新しい考え方が生まれやすくなる
これは自分の出身校である
普通部の生徒さんたちに
この視点を変えたり
多次元的な発想法の
ワークショップを行っている光景です
これ分かりますか？
みんなで木になっているところです
樹木の木ですね
自分たちが木になって
人間ではなく 自分が
木だとしたら何を感じるのか？
世界をどう見るのか？
よく言われる環境問題
人間の立場で環境を見るのではなく
自分が伐採されている木だとしたら
自分が住処を奪われている動物だとしたら
何を感じるのか？
そうなったときに
それは環境問題ではなく
自分の問題に変わります
そんな風に立脚点を
変えていくことが出来たらば
いろいろな新しい発想 新しい生き方が
生まれてくるのではないでしょうか？
[常識の枠から一歩踏み出そう]
本当に
いつも生活している普段の生活
ここから一歩踏み出す事
それにはお金もいらないし
何のデバイスもいらない
自分の身体と自分の心があれば
その代り ちょっとだけ普段の生活を離れる勇気
それが必要になります
それは人から否定され
そんなのおかしいと言われるかもしれない
空気読めないって言われるかもしれない
だけども そこから
僅かでも一歩踏み出したとき
新しい世界が広がってくる
みんなひとりひとりが
自分自身のオリジナリティを生み出して
世界と関わっていく
そんな時代が来ることを
心から望んでいます
今日は本当にありがとうございました
（拍手）